hello and welcome to the new world
viewer source for everything anime and
manga and we are back to talk about what
this anti-magic child does before
during and indeed after spats of yelling
seriously i'm only reading the manga and
i am getting hit with the full
force of asta's vocal range but more
specifically we are here to talk about
arc
number three of black clover which i
believe is named the royal capital r
another very fun and surprising set of
chapters that give me that very familiar
feeling of starting off in quite a
generic place before taking those
concepts one step further than your
average shown shonen series and i really
enjoyed this arc actually honestly
probably not quite as much as the
dungeon exploration but there is a ton
to digest here regardless and before i
engage in digestion please do take a
moment to digest this request to
subscribe to the new old review as per
usual i probably won't be reading these
comments due to fear of spoilers so
subscribing through this video and
liking this video are the only ways i
can really tell if you want more of
black
clover but the premise of our third arc
goes as follows after doing some
seriously
cool stuff in the dungeon asta yuno and
friends of astor and yuno are invited to
the royal capital in order to file a
report with mr wizardking himself and
while they're here they meet all sorts
of nobility and general high-ranking
mages some of which are pricks some of
which are amazing and others are just
meh so meh that they may as well not
even be there however everyone must then
work together when the capital is
attacked by dark magical cultists led
by crazy people it's a fine premise the
stating of which does the ark no justice
whatsoever because just as with the
previous arc most of the substance here
lies with internal character evolution
intriguing interactions
and the overall theme of the arc which
is benchmarking and we're going to start
this discussion with the latter because
in practically every shonen series the
plucky young protagonist
will eventually hit a wall something
that their unique power and relentless
determination is simply
unable to overcome in any circumstances
thus giving them a benchmark to surpass
in the future
now black clover takes that concept a
step further with the royal capital arc
and while subtle
it gives us a road map for going forward
with an almost step-by-step guide as to
how either asta or yuno is going to
become the wizard king and it begins
pretty damn immediately by showcasing
the magic knight ranking system which is
very simple but very effective there are
five grand ranks and within each of
those five they are divided into a
further five subclasses
it's a lot of fives there but assuming
that the wizard king does not have that
subclass system this would give us
20 levels of magic night progress that
we will need to travel through before
the idea
of wizard king becomes anywhere near
tangible and i love this by the way
because i said this in the last video
but i crave rules and structure the last
dark provided that for magic and this
arc provides that for organizational
structure now with that said how does
this help us in regards to asda well
it's tricky because he doesn't seem to
initially fit anywhere here given that
his current rank isn't mentioned to the
best of my knowledge maybe it didn't i
missed it but i would have to assume
that he is a junior magic knight fifth
class aka the lowest of the ranks but
technical definitions are
only half of the truth here in reality
tarbita does something very interesting
to kind of let us know where asta is
power wise and that comes in the
character of leopold it might be quite a
comical aspect of the arc but leopold
declares asta his rival and throughout
the ensuing events these two are often
depicted as equals especially at the end
where they're both fighting like rapid
animals and leopold just so happens to
be an intermediate magic knight
second class so regardless of any
official ranking this seems to me about
where asta sits which is a step or two
above entry level but he still has a
long way to go
and from there our next benchmark is
seen in the squad captains asta is
thoroughly outclassed by both juego leon
and nozzle meanwhile these two are shown
to be thoroughly outclassed by the power
of the wizard king who is himself
also potentially outclassed by the
mystery villain at the end of the arc
thus giving us these really tangible
steps to be taken by astor and yuno we
now have something to benchmark them
against going forward and this arc
essentially allows us to track their
progress on a chart if we so saw fit
it's not just aster and you know either
most of the key characters in this arc
have some sort of benchmark set for them
leopold for example is now very directly
on a quest to surpass fuego leon and
even become the wizard king himself and
you know what even noel has a new
benchmark which
is admittedly minor but it is present
and it is simply not to remain weak
which is one of the best lines in the
arc actually when fuego leon tells her
that being weak is nothing to be ashamed
of but staying weak is
i really love that what i did not love
however is both noel and mimosa all of a
sudden being all smitten with
asta because i hate this trope so so
much i mean yeah i enjoyed it as a
teenager
i don't know though as a man in his
early 30s there is a limit to how much i
can tolerate awkwardly written love
struck 15 year old girls and i really
really really hope this isn't how
they're both going to be going forward
for the next
i don't know however long this series is
but now we're introduced to a whole ton
of new characters in this arc which i
think is both a good
and a bad thing on the one hand i really
love that tabitha is consistently
filling this world with as much
content as he can muster which in this
case comes in the form of an ass ton of
characters
i like it because it winds our focus
beyond the asta centric groups but at
times that focus can get a bit too wide
even for me
one example would be early on when we
see all of the magic knights receiving
their promotions
we see leopold get his and that's nice
then we see seoul get hers and that's
also nice but then you turn the page and
it's just this
two-page spread of like five other
people being promoted one by one
and i just stopped caring immediately
for the most part it was fine though i
don't mind these unique faces popping up
and not being explored too deeply
because that just effectively fills the
world
just please no more two-page spreads of
people i don't care about being promoted
and i will say this feeling also extends
into some of the action of the arc
there's a part near the beginning of all
of the fighting where we have like
six pages in a row of prominent magic
nights just firing off their mage
juices and if i stop and look at all of
the panels they're all cool in their own
way but after like the third page of
watching around a magic knight unload a
spell i was kind of over it because to
me that really killed the pacing of the
chapter
action is supposed to be fast and
exciting you know one or two bursts
would have been great however when we
linger and go through
every single mages opening attack one by
one
over the course of six pages then it
makes me feel like i'm stuck in the
wizard king's chronostasis spell like
i'm living in this one
unending moment and given that most of
these spells are shown later on in the
arc anyway you really didn't need to
cram them all in here because not only
did it slow everything down but tabitha
also blew his load for revealing them in
a more exciting way later on anyway
that's enough negativity let's move on
and talk about some negativity so some
of these new characters just so happen
to be noel's relatives and they're quite
essential here two older brothers and
one older sister of house silver and i
hate these people
each and every single one of them can go
screw themselves in the most
uncomfortable way possible however i
love this dynamic
i hate them because they're designed to
be hated and it leads to a great moment
with asda telling them all to f off
early on and you know not in those words
but it is nice to see the underdog put
these pricks in their place
with that said noel's relatives do have
one redeeming feature so far in nozzle
he has a brief flashback at the end of
the arc to highlight his camaraderie and
or rivalry with juego leon
and that was really nice in many ways
yes he is still a complete and utter
[ __ ] but at least he has a lot more
depth than the other over the [ __ ]
and speaking of juego leon i've brought
him up a lot already but i love him the
moment where he told astor that you and
i are rivals as well is all i needed to
sell me on him he is absolutely
fantastic in every way which is of
course why he had to be hurt hurt
quite badly even because we care about
him and that makes him a very effective
target for drama and as for those who
were doing the hurting the main villains
of this arc aren't quite as interesting
to me as lotus and mars i think those
two really were something special but
i suppose these guys will do i mean
rydez had an intriguing inferiority
complex going on trying to prove himself
to be better than all of the nobles who
would look down upon him and on top of
that
the dude only had one spell i mean what
a loser but also not really because he
does of course remind me a lot of asda
looked down upon
cast aside and really only has this one
narrow yet incredibly effective talent
radez has asked her if he went down a
darker road which i guess he is pursuing
the power of what may be a literal devil
so we'll see about that but in regards
to writers his magic was also quite
interesting i do like how he managed to
use his one spell to provide this
amazing level of versatility and i did
also
quite like his design i just wasn't 100
sold on him though i understand his
motivation to a degree
you know getting revenge on the pompous
people that's always a good one but
there is a massive gap between that and
you know trying to murder children for
fun
all in all he was just a bit more
generically evil than i would have liked
and a bit less interesting as a result
and i'd say the same for old lady who i
think is named catherine i prefer what
you know caught her though and actually
don't really know what to say about her
i mean
she was there she was certainly there
and there was even a third one as well
it doesn't matter something that
is important is that they all seem to
know about asta's auntie magic and i
want to know how to my knowledge that's
not something that's been widely
publicized and really the only people
who should know are those within the
magic knights or those who took and
failed the exam
which i suppose may mean we have a
traitor in our midst which is always fun
if so and in regards to other things
yuno was understated but fantastic
during the sock he got deprived of his
five senses and learned to connect with
his new fairy friend
who is apparently silf a mightily opie
win spirit and one of the four great
attributes which does excite me because
i now eagerly await the discovery of the
other three
and as for the wizard king himself i
still don't really know how to feel
about him he's quite charming and
eccentric whilst also harboring this
fairly terrifying potential not just in
terms of raw power but his beliefs can
be fairly harsh as well like when he
just up and murdered some fools stating
that well they were prepared to die
right as well as almost appearing to
take pleasure in the idea of torturing
them through the cronus stasis spell so
at the moment i really don't quite see
him as the role model aster does because
this dude has some pretty damn dark
features in addition to that apparently
there is a non-wizard king in this world
as well someone who prefers to be
adorned by mysterious shrouds and many
many
assumedly beautiful human females and he
seems to be set up to be a pretty
obvious bad dude dick right now but i
suppose it's nice to know that magic
isn't everything in this world like it's
not as if the wizard king just rules the
entire nation like i initially thought
he might oh and also charmy was here i
like her she's cute and furiously
powerful
she had nothing to do with anything but
she was admittedly a nice break from all
of the serious business happening
elsewhere but yeah the royal capital arc
was quite good overall it was much more
of a mixed bag than the dungeon
exploration one but i'm quite glad that
asterisk hit his wall now because we can
begin working on getting beyond that and
slowly working our way up the tier
system that has been set up for us but
that pretty much does it for this blind
review of the royal capital arc and what
do you guys think please do leave your
thoughts in the comments below or even
join my discord server and if you're
keen for some more black clover content
then please do go and check out some of
my other videos or even subscribe to the
channel
for very maybe black clover goodness
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review
and i'll see you next time